We’re rolling, Julian.
What?
We’re rolling!
Are you deaf?
… What?
What’s up my knowledgeable audiophiles,
Julian here for DNews.
I don’t know if you’ve heard but scientists
have recently made a breakthrough restoring
the hearing of mice who had been deafened
by loud noises.
Researchers from the University of Michigan
and Harvard Medical School manipulated the
genes of mice so their inner ears made more
of the protein Neurotrophin-3, or NT3.
Then they partially deafened them with loud
noise, presumably by blasting nickelback.
After 2 weeks, mice with increased levels
of NT-3 showed much improved hearing compared
to the control group.
So how does it work?
Well the nerve cells connected to the hair
follicles in your cochlea have a special structure
at the synapse, called a ribbon, so named
because it looks nothing like a ribbon.
Ribbon synapses allow for super fast, precise,
and sustained neurotransmission, which makes
them ideal for transmitting sight and sound.
In your ear, these synapses get damaged with
noise or age.
That’s where the NT-3 comes in.
NT-3 helps keep older neurons alive and promotes
the regeneration of new neurons and synapses.
Dr. Gabriel Corfas, who led the study, is
optimistic increasing NT-3 can restore hearing
in partially deafened humans too.
He even believes it can be done with a drug
instead of the gene therapy they used for
the mice.
That’s big news, considering that 50 million
americans have hearing loss in at least 1
ear and 47% of adults over 75 have difficulty
hearing.
When you consider that ear buds are ubiquitous
and can basically project a rock concert directly
into your ear, that percentage is going to
be much higher by the time my generation is
septuagenarians.
So thanks to Dr. Corfas, I’m going to go
ahead and keep rocking out on the subway guilt-free,
even if it’s clearly weirding everybody
out.
For more proof that loud music damages your
hearing, Tara sounds off about it here.
So, is the risk of hearing loss worth having
your tunes at all times?
Do you ever really think about it?
Let me hear about it in the comments.
Trust me, I hear everything.
See you next time on DNews.